das fragen lotto mit spieleentwickler
pukki jan müller michaelis der unter
anderem erklärt warum man als
spieleentwickler ein kind bleiben muss
und was er von ego shootern hält da
scheint er nämlich ein ziemlich genug zu
sein
das und viel mehr jetzt in fragen lotto
es kommt nämlich jetzt ihr wisst was das
ist genau das ist das fragen lotto also
die roten sind gemeinde fragen die
grünen sind harmlose frage du kannst
selbst wählen du kannst du viel ziehen
wie du möchtest weniger ziehen was du
mal was okay wir haben brutale fragen
genau die roten sind gemein
ok ich da hält sich fies ich bin total
entspannt auf die hinterhältige fragen
deswegen nämlich diejenigen fragen
obwohl die anderen so könnten auch sie
hier ab und drehen sie auf eigentlich
waren das drei wussten die dritte
hinterhältige stern clips hand in die
kameras auf ok kannst du mit mikro
mikrofon ist es echt schwierig
ah das ist eine schwierige frage
aber ich habe meine diese auch nicht
gemeint ok dann wirst du endlich mal
erwachsen dass tatsächlich eine frage
auf die ich mit sehr großem stolz
antworten können
er kann man kann einfach keine spiele
programmieren ohne einen ausgeprägten
peter pan komplex und den habe ich ich
werde niemals erwachsen ich höre das ist
ein sensationeller du drehst eine
einseitig an deiner seite dann okay
dienst tatsächlich so kannst du
eigentlich auch was anderes als immer
nur neue version von monkey island zu
entwickeln die einfach gut
ich hab nix gelernt ich kann euch
bezeichnen den krakeligen hintergründen
sieht deswegen habe ich habe versucht zu
bügeln vor der gamescom ist auch total
schief gegangen ich glaube ich kann
nichts anderes
nein ich hoffe ja dass wir dass wir halt
irgendwie mit unseren geschichten
bisschen was anderes machen als backend
ich hoffe es einfach das ist halt auch
irgendwie durchdringt die sich bei den
leuten die sich mit unseren spielen
beschäftigen
es war halt neben neben den monkey
island clown den wir natürlich
tatsächlich benutzen also wir nehmen das
game design von monkey island und pinsel
einfach drüber aber wir fühlten außerdem
halt nur noch noch zusätzlich ein
bisschen stimmt was sie dir mal vor
schritten in ein anderes genre zu gehen
natürlich kann ich mir das vorstellen
aber nicht solange ich nicht die davon
überzeugt bin dass das gut für die
geschichte ist okay das wort so was wir
haben irgendwie fehlt hier drin wir
haben noch eine böse frage ich lese sie
mal vor also wir tun wir so als hätte
die gezogene so da stehts jetzt quasi
drauf die heißt macht ihr diese
niedlichen comic spielt ihn eigentlich
nur weil er einen ordentlichen schub mit
geiler grafik sowieso nicht hinkriegen
würde also ich muss sagen ich bin ganz
furchtbar schlecht in shootern und
deswegen habe ich auch nie gerne
gespielt es ist also ich bin einfach
fürchterlich
damals hatte ich hab ja auch ich bin ja
auch methusalem der gamesbranche und da
hat es damals die ersten drei spiele
raus kamen habe ich noch ein furchtbarer
drei den ausseer gelitten das heißt mir
wurde schlecht vor dem 1
doch das hat sich natürlich mittlerweile
vollkommen erledigen also man kann so
was ja auch um sich abtrainieren
sozusagen
aber vielleicht das im hinterkopf darum
was von hängen geblieben dass ich halt
irgendwie immer noch so ein bisschen
oder so keine ahnung ich spiele sehr
gerne
action rollenspiele
trans ich bin eigentlich alles mögliche
gerne aber shooter spiele ich einfach
nicht gerne
es ist ich weiß ich habe nie dazu
gefunden ich glaube ich möchte ich
möchte einfach auch weil sie nicht so
viel wert auf story oder ich weiß nicht
was es ist vielseitig gerne ruhig mal
nicht gerne oder gut aber ich möchte
auch einmal noch nett zu dir sein wo die
bitte zum zum ende wenn du noch eine
grüne frage ziehen würdest stimmt gerade
ich habe letzte woche sehr sehr sehr
entzückt gears of war 3 gespielt da habe
ich doch geballert und habe ich mich so
schlecht angestellt hatte ich mich zu
dem ich angestellt habe
doch ich versuche immer viel zu spielen
aber es klappt hat nicht in jedem
produktionsphasen manchmal manchmal
kommt man tatsächlich nicht dazu
manchmal kommt man auch nicht zum
schlafen aber aktuell spiele ich doch
das ein oder andere mal wieso sind deine
lieben videospiel charaktere so
liebenswert ja das ist eigentlich viel
schwieriger zu beantworten so was ja gut
weg die sind schwer zu beantworten aber
sie sind nicht genau das speichert und
ist ja nachdem ich hier halt dort wie
eine watschn acht andere bekommen habt
ja keine ahnung vielleicht beim
eintippen liebenswertes in hamburg okay
die müssen die zeichnen und halt
irgendwie quasi ins spiel rein
programmieren
und die sind das sind alles so
exzellente leute und ich denke mal das
färbt irgendwie ab also wenn ich sie
designe sind sie doch total schrecklich
und liebenswert aber dann gehen sie halt
durch die langen bälle kühle und wenn
sie nachher im spiel sind dann nachher
total sympathisch geworden weil durch
das ganze sympathische delikt feeling
daran abgerubbelt hat okay das heißt
wichtig ist ein sympathisches team
zusammen zum gelungen entwickeln auf
jeden fall sobald uns dann geh mal was
ein sympathischer gast profilen und
lustig auch in fragen lotte auf jeden
fall floyd der erklärt dass gewalt
unterhaltsam ist und hasuobs auch sehr
lustig den peek ich nämlich darauf an
sind gamer langweilig er erklärt es ist
es so dass es nicht und einfach beiden
könnt euch anschauen
bis dann